mr. Nelson you have brought mrs. fuller
here in an effort to get $600 a month
transitional support for the next three
years for a total of 20 $1,600 before we
discuss that request for transitional
support however mr. Nelson tell me a
little bit about your marriage and why
we're here in divorce court today all
right well it's pretty much like this
you know I can say I'm like the regular
kind of guy you know what I mean like
you know I stay at home you know I cook
I clean
that's not regular look forgot here I
was about to get another haircut my wife
she isn't she's an appreciative of
anything that I do actually you know
what I'm gonna do something special for
you know sorts I set the table you know
I got everything put the moon music on
you not me so when she comes in the door
it's like what is all this we got this
why are you using my Grandmamma dishes
why you did like why ain't you got no
jet light and it's just like wow mrs.
fuller
you see he's gonna get this but what
he's telling me you've got a cooking
cleaning romancing and not bad-looking
fella on your hands what seems to be the
problem
well first off when we first met you
know he led me to believe you know I
understood he didn't have a job mm-hmm
it's a bad economy a lot of people don't
have a job right yeah but he bamboozled
me he throw it in and made it seem like
he couldn't get a job he wasn't working
right now he had all these plans to get
a job eventually he was working on in
everybody I know it's been three years
and he has every that would and then he
goes it that was there all day every day
and say how he works on the house and
cooks dinner let me tell you this we
have a studio apartment so
where could it be and it possibly take
you to clean up your home every day all
day and I'm not talking about full
course meals when I get home you know I
have Hamburger Helper I don't got a side
of vegetables
I don't got dessert you don't make me a
drink I'm actually gonna be other guys
after this one you know I mean if it was
I stay-at-home mom
and the husband comes home he'd be like
the meals aren't good enough you know
then you don't clean enough space it's
not big enough for you to clean
therefore you don't deserve alimony that
[ __ ] would never fly important because
it's a staff home dad right we treated
essence you would would you permit
yourself to talk about a woman who stays
at home - absolutely
okay well the court system definitely
doesn't know the curse but I would I
would at least clean know it's clean but
I could clean the studio apartment
myself when I got home from work that's
not a big deal you know it's not a
full-time job I don't need a maid I
think there no children's no children
clean in a studio you say it's not quite
enough of a contribution mr. Nelson did
you tell her that you said look I want
to be a house husband that's the kind of
information no I didn't tell her that
but I mean like you you should like I
feel like somebody should catch signs
you know I mean like like when we met we
met I was at the bus stop and she was
driving I got the [ __ ] out of here at
the bus stop
she was driving she was like on the
phone or something would it we'll
probably one of her friends or something
like that kind of flag her down like hey
baby how you doing you know and we kind
of took a flag you down at a Buffy okay
flagged me down at a bus stop I'll give
him that
I appreciate that he flagged her down a
bus stop caught a ride be classier while
she drove the way the man became a
metaphor for their entire relationship
with the weed haha
you smart I know I know but listen I bet
have in your car you deserve everything
that happens after you need to be
deserve didn't happen - yeah she chose
to marry him she News character if you
choose to marry someone their deadbeat
don't be surprised after marriage if
there's still a deadbeat that was your
choice if after the word you want to
divorce them and think you know all the
money well no you made that financial
obligation to them
contractually speaking to marry them so
that's all on you
the same way for man marries a woman she
becomes a stay-at-home mom and then they
get divorced and she gets alimony you
know how the system works
you signed into it so I don't feel bad
for you I hope this girl ends up paying
thousands of dollars for a dumbass
mistake for better or worse for better
or worse than [ __ ] you news gonna be
worse right from the moon you picked
that [ __ ] for the bus stop sighs I can
just sum this up
you were trifling and she should have
known it and if she married you when you
were trifling she's got to live what a
trifling guy cuz all the signs were
there has no shame yeah
who paid his rent before you you said he
had an apartment how do you how do you
manage that I'm guessing from school
homes I don't know I'm gonna get horn
you listen here man you guessing about
how he's paying him around check on the
dude yes baby what is not a background
check it is a common question mr. Nelson
how are you paying your rent you know
your junk mail when you check your email
and like Google it's like the if--and
like Google and they're like I'll work
from home right it was like thank you
that's me right that's you I don't care
this is Krypton up this is genius
whoever wrote this good it's pretty good
to start one time I came home my mom
she's like I got a job - I win it's one
of them Google - she acts hey listen to
the hole whoa what is that it's like you
know when you hit a pop up and they're
like do you want to make $13,000 a month
working from home your mom water to make
thirteen thousand a month working from
home well that after before you paid her
rent
yo my mom's a gangster my mom wants to
make money all the time my mom's always
got she always pretends her money issues
are way worse than what they are no cuz
you're gonna hustle me so your mom is a
taxi driver Oh what name I your pop owns
my Oh Bible
bad better Cote by you Baba but it's a
rare event where I see the woman talking
about the man not giving her enough sex
I mean I guess it's a rare occasion but
it's happened today I feel like it's not
very rare I have a normal sex drive you
know I do like sex you know I see
nothing wrong with that I like to have
sex with my husband I don't think
there's anything wrong with that he's
having to complain all the time talking
about making excuses I get home from
work working 10-hour days get home he's
been home and playing video games on
Facebook I feel like when I get home the
least he could do is take care of my
section 1 DT is my husband it's not like
he's doing anything else all day no man
talk about his woman know that she needs
to do my sexual needs the least she
could do all she does is cook and clean
you know we'll never let that [ __ ] fly
listen I like [ __ ] some of you ladies
got some sex drives like you trying to
compete a prayer was my least music
video here ok talking about all night
long no [ __ ] this should only last an
hour so beyond that you guys are just
pushing it too much there now 5 minutes
hey I'm gonna get mine hmm I hope you
get yours after that I'm out of time to
sign I didn't want to take a second job
there's no reason why I need an
instruction manual to make you [ __ ]
girlfriend you need to simplify that
[ __ ] right stop pulling your friends
turn your [ __ ] into Cray all make my
life easier you know we should have
t-shirts that said a Cleon we fix French
thank you exaggeration you know the
truth there's one thing like you her sex
drive just like she has like Energizer
Bunny syndrome yeah I mean like keep
going and going
she says when she comes home from work
like that does not that does not mean
like she came home like Oh after a hard
day's work that means like I took a
15-minute break and I'm coming home so
we can have sex then on my lunch break I
want you to cook for me and then we can
have sex and I'll go back to work and
then I'm gonna take my last 15-minute
break and then we're gonna have some
more sex because I just love it that
much my husband would shoot people to be
in your position that's what I'm saying
your husband don't know what the [ __ ]
he's talking on he doesn't I'm there
with a girl who has too much of a sex
ride where it's just that all the time
listen my penis gets worn up all right
literally it's constant chafing against
the sugar walls you know I'm saying
after a while you start to feel diabetic
okay you're [ __ ] goats up up yo D
that's how it started you know what I
mean I was like oh yeah like all four
you know cuz it was cool like you know
but like it was like we were it was on
occasion you know it was great sex on a
case occasion then occasions to be every
day well I don't want it to be 17
thousand times per second like I want it
to be why I wanted to give me a rest
like like I'm not Superman
I saw him sleep of course I'm sleep you
know after a night of sex that we
probably just had you know so she wakes
me up you know with the hands in the
pants you know and that's cool like like
fellas that's cool right that's
everybody feel like that's cool but 30
45 minutes that's cool ladies is that 30
45 minutes we're not taking a survey
mister
though I will admit the hands in the
fancy when I wake up that's always a
nice move all right it's not very
consensual the moment I wake my pants
save a little bit for you yes forever
and ever
hey depends is nice very nice yeah what
is nice you know but are you dating
someone you're comfortable you don't
need their consent if you're dating me
don't need the Gazeta
you know why I'm secret just but with
your permission to set that down there
people aren't what they tell you they're
all they are what they do he was doing
what he does which was nothing when you
met him it's nothing now and it will
continue to be nothing because as he
says this is his vision of life so you
can't pretend it's something other than
what it is and for the life of me I
never understand why people do not sit
down and have a conversation about what
it is I expect because you're making a
commitment for here on and you're not
going to talk about what it is and what
it isn't mr. Nelson you're lazy
[Applause]
laziness is not a vision it's not a
calling it's not a way arise laziness is
a character like a church laziness is
not a way of life is not a common it's
not none of you [ __ ] if you so decide a
similar saya a similar Sunnah to be lazy
other your life yes God then so be it
but you should say it to your partner
can I get it scratch my balls scratch my
balls
that's what here we go this is what
listen
years ago when they started this alimony
thing it was all based upon the
principle that women stay at home and
cook and clean and take care of the
children and the men work and bring home
the money now we have a circumstances
where they are where it is flipped what
I often see though in this Court is
women who are working and cooking and
cleaning and taking care of the kids
guys at home with the PlayStation in the
Facebook and I don't believe
transitional support is appropriate
under those circumstances if you're not
bringing anything to the table at all
you just kicking back but that's not
what he did he didn't do something what
much but he did do something now
whatever it was that you were doing
before you found her to pay your rent
you're gonna need to start doing that
again but I'm gonna give you a minute
and I just mean a minute to get it
together I'm going to award you $500 a
month for the next three months
not the twenty one thousand you were
looking for fifteen hundred give him the
five hundred dollars a month all lessons
cost money
all you have to pay for stupid decisions
five hundred dollars a month for the
next 20 months $1,500 in paper mr.
Nelson it is so ordered
Molly nubile eyes that if that was the
roles reverse insects reverse there's no
way to judge with a spoke like that you
don't give her enough sex you know or
you don't give him enough sets I mean
your cleaning is not up to standard your
cooking is not up to standard
therefore you don't deserve money
there's no way that she would have flak
so it's a bit of a double staying in
that regard set from that dogs had some
good laughs those are ridiculous
ridiculous story you saw happen not to
watch this video and not subscribe so
help you God thanks for watching most
ridiculous tears alright so that's it
for today's video if you guys like that
be sure to LIKE subscribe Facebook
YouTube
we don't put everything on Facebook
because YouTube's our main bits follow
us on Instagram all that good stuff
we got a patreon page so if you want it
don't need a little bit of money you
know give us a little thumbs up know we
do well that's it so you know thanks
holler a dollar makes me holler